สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงแล้วก็
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนอ่ะเดี๋ยวขอแชร์สีนเขียนวันที่
ก่อนนะคะครับครูนิกวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้
วันพุธ
ครับวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 3 ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคม
ครับปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ครับปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้นะ
ครับเมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่เนี่ยเวลา 85 นค่ะ
นตอนเช้าเนาะใช่ตอนเช้าครับ
แล้วตอนนี้เมืองที่ครูหนิงครูหญิงอยู่กี่
โมงครับเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่ตอนนี้อ่า
95 นค่ะอืมแล้วก็โอเคตอนเช้าตอนเช้า
เหมือนกันเหมือนกันใช่แล้วอืมเร็วกว่าของ
ครูนิก 1 ชมคะอ่า 1 ช่มโอเคอืเอ่อูหญิง
ปกติปกติเวลาคุยอืผู้หญิงออกไปข้างนอก
บ่อยมยตั้งแต่มาอยู่ที่อเมริกาเนี่ยก็ไม่
ค่อยบ่อยขนาดนั้นนะคะแต่ก็ออกไปข้างนอก
อยู่อ๋อโอเคแล้วเวลาออกไปข้างนอกนี่ปกติ
ไปยังไงครับเดินไปหรือนั่งรถนั่งรถฟไป
เรียกว่าอะไรรถไฟฟ้าหรือไม่รู้ว่าเค้าใช้
อะไรที่เป็นขนส่งสาธารณะที่เมืองที่ครู
หญิงอยู่คือถ้าไป
แบบแถวใกล้ๆบ้านใช่มั้ยใกล้ๆบริเวณที่
อยู่เนี่ยก็เดินค่ะเดินไปแต่ถ้าสมมุติจะ
เข้าไปในเมืองครับไปที่ที่ไกล้ๆหน่อยก็
มันจะมีขนส่งก็คือรถไฟฟ้าซับเวย์เนาะที่
นี่เเรียกว่าซวใช่ครับจริงๆก็มีรถเมล์นะ
แต่รู้สึกเหมือนคนก็นั่งรถไฟฟ้าอืออือแต่
ว่าถ้านั่งรถไฟฟ้าเข้าไปในเมืองแล้วอ่ะ
ค่ะอยากจะไปที่ไหนก็เดินอืมเหมือนคนที่
นี่นิยมเดินนะคะใช่ใช่คนิดก็คิดเหมือนกัน
ว่าคนที่นี่เนี่ยเขาชอบเดินแล้วก็เพราะ
ว่าอยากรู้ว่าครูหญิงมาที่เนี่ยครูหญิง
คิดว่าเวลาไปข้างนอกเนี่ยครูหญิงเดินบ่อย
กว่าอยู่ที่ไทยมั้ยโอโหคุหญิคือถ้าวันไหน
ที่ครูหญิงออกไปข้างนอกบ้านน่ะค่ะครูหญิง
เดินมากกว่า
19,000 เออคือเออถ้าอยู่กรุงเทพฯอ่ะถึง
แม้ว่าจะออกไปไปไปข้างนอกบ้านนะคะเดิน
เต็มที่ก็ประมาณ 3,000 ถึง 5,000 อ่ะเออ
แค่นั้นเออแต่อยู่ที่นี่ไม่มีนะคอย่าง
น้อยเลยเนี่ยถ้าออกนอกบ้านเนี่ย 19,000
เออใช่เดินเยอะมากใช่ก็อันนี้เนี่ยคือคือ
ครุณนิกเนี่ยชอบเดินอยู่แล้วครูนิกก็เลย
ไม่ได้รู้สึกอะไรเพราะว่าตอนอยู่ที่ไทย
ครูนิกก็เดินบ่อยบางทีอ่ะเคยขี้เกียจขึ้น
รถไฟฟ้าใช่มั้ยครับคุณนิกก็เคยมีอยู่
ครั้งนึงนะเดินจากช่องนนทรีอ่ะไป
สยาม
เดี๋ยวครูนิกนั่งรถไฟฟ้าก็แป๊บเดียวเองนะ
คะใช่แต่คือช่ซีไฟสยามครูนิกก็ไม่รู้ว่า
ทำไมถึงไม่นั่งรถไฟฟ้าเพราะว่ามันก็ไม่
ได้มันก็แค่ 2  2 ประมาณ 2  23
สถานีแต่คุณนิไม่รู้ว่าคิดอะไรอยู่ตอน
นั้นรู้สึกว่าเอ้อไม่รีบไม่ต้องขึ้นรถไฟ
ฟ้าก็ได้เดินดินดูแล้วก็ดูใน Google  map
มันก็บอกว่าประมาณ 40  45 นาทีเราก็เลย
เออ
ก็ไม่ต้องขึ้นก็ได้เนาะเดินไปเรื่อยๆแล้ว
ก็เดี๋ยวก็ถึงแล้วก็ไปหาข้าวกินก็คิดแบบ
นี้อืหรือจริงๆอาจจะเป็นเพราะว่าร้าน
อาหารที่อยากกินยังไม่เปิดก็เลยไม่ได้รีบ
หรือเปล่าใช่แต่ก็นั่นแหละครับก็คือนิก
เนี่ยเป็นคนชอบเดินอยู่แล้วอืค่ะคือคุณ
อิงกลังจะบอกว่าครูนิก็ถือจะเป็นคนไทย
ปกติมยอันนี้ไม่แน่ใจนะคะแต่ว่าคนไทยหรือ
ว่าเพื่อนหรือว่าทุกคนที่อยู่รอบๆตัวไม่
มีใครชอบเดินนะเจะบอกว่าเดินในกรุงเทพฯ
หรือว่าเดินในประเทศไทยเนี่ยมันลำบากนะ
มันไม่ได้สบายแบบเหมือนเวลาเราไปต่าง
ประเทศเออใช่จริงๆอ่ะเพื่อนครูนิกก็คิด
แบบนั้นแหละเพราะเขาคก็บอกว่าอ่ะเพื่อน
ครูนิกนะครั้งแรกอันดับแรกเลยเนี่ยคือ
กลัวดำอ๋อโอเคเข้าใจเพราะว่ามันร้อนครู
หญิงเนี่ยดำขึ้นนะมาอยู่ที่นี่เนี่ยจริงๆ
คุณนี้ก็คิดว่าน่าจะดำขึ้นแต่ว่าเราไม่
รู้ตัวเพราะอากาศมันไม่ร้อนเหมือนที่ไทย
แล้วก็อีกอย่างนึงเค้าเหมือนกับว่ามัน
อย่างที่ครูหญิงพูดนี่แหละเดินในกรุงเทพฯ
มันไม่มันไม่ได้สบายหรือมันก็ไม่ได้สบาย
หรอกเดินแต่แค่ว่ามันไม่สะดวกเหมือนต่าง
ประเทศอเอาอย่างง่ายๆเลยครับเวลาบนฟุตบาต
หรือข้ามถนนเนี่ยข้ามถนนที่ไทยอ่าถ้าพูด
คือในกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยก็มันก็ไม่ได้ง่าย
เหมือนอย่างที่ต่างประเทศอ่าใช่เลยค่ะ
อย่างผู้หญิงอยู่ที่นี่ใช่มยคะแบบเมือง
เนี้ยคือมันเป็นเมืองของการเดินน่ะอเดินๆ
ๆๆๆแล้วก็ข้ามถนนแบบบ่อยมากๆอ่ะค่ะคือ
อยู่ที่นี่ก็เลยเข้าใจแบบเมื่อก่อนที่ดู
หนังแล้วคนอเมริกาบอกว่าว่าโอเคเดิน
ประมาณ 2 บล็อก 3 บล็อกครับอย่างเงี้ย
เมื่อก่อนเราก็ไม่เข้าใจเพราะกรุงเทพฯ
บ้านเราไม่มีอือ่าแต่ที่นี่มันจะเป็นแบบ
เป็นบล็อกถนนเหมือนเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมใช่ใช่
ก็อืครับแล้วเราเดินนั้นใช่อืคือเราก็
เดินข้ามถนนบ่อยมากเราก็รู้สึกแบบเออมัน
ไม่ยากเนาะครับอืคืออยู่ประเทศไทยรู้สึก
แบบฉันต้องดูซ้ายดูขวาดูหน้าดูดูหลังดู
ทั้งหมดอ่ะอ่าดูทั้งหมดแล้วก็คือถ้าจะรู้
สึกปลอดภัยนิดนึงเนี่ยก็คือถ้าเขามีกด
สัญญาณไฟอันนั้นน่ะคนก็จะจอดค่ะเหมือนกับ
รถเนี่ยก็จะจอดแต่ว่าก็ไม่ใช่รถทุกคันนะ
ในประเทศไทยรถมอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยไม่จอดไม่
จอด 100% ใช่คือไม่เข้าใจว่าทำไมถึงไม่
จอดก็คือคุณนิดก็มาคิดว่าเคยมีครั้งนึง
คุณนิดก็ข้ามถนนในกรุงเทพฯแถวๆสีลมแล้วก็
กดสัญญาณไฟนะปกติพอเค้าให้ข้ามคุณนี้ก็
ข้ามก็จะมีมอเตอร์ไซค์พยายามที่จะเหมือน
กับเบียดเข้ามาเบียดให้มันแบบเค้าขับไป
ได้อ่ะอืคุณนิก็มาคิดว่ามันมีสัญญาณไฟ
คูนี่เคยชี้ครั้งนึงมันก็
เนี่ยมันต้องหยุดนะไฟแรงเออเก็ไม่ใจเก็
อู้แล้วแบบมันก็เราเราก็อันตรายใช่มมคือ
เราก็กลัวนะเพราะว่าเราก็รู้สึกว่าเอ้ย
อย่างเงี้ยมันไม่ปลอดภัยหรือเปล่าแล้ว
ทำไมคนถึงไม่ทำตามกฎจราจรอือืว่าแบบเฮ้ย
ของคุณเนี่ยไฟแดงคุณต้องจอดอืใช่มไม่ไม่
ใช่ไฟเขียวทำไมคุณคุณถึงมาอ่าคุณถึงขับรถ
ไปอันนี้มันใช่
แต่อันเนี้ยในความคิดครูนิกนะครูนิกคิด
ว่าเพราะเค้าคิดว่าเค้าเนี่ยรถขนาดเล็ก
เหมือนจักรยานหรือเปล่าค่ะพอคิดว่าขนาด
เล็กเหมือนจักรยานจักรยานไม่จำเป็นต้องรอ
ไฟแดงหรือไฟเขียวเค้าก็เลยมีความคิดแบบ
นั้นมั้งครับอืหรือว่าเค้าอาจจะชินมั้ย
กับการที่ไม่ต้องรอให้คนข้ามอ่ะคือเหมือน
เาไม่ต้องรอใครอ่ะอ่าถ้าครูนิกจะข้ามถนน
ครูนิกต้องรอเขาใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าครูนิก
ต้องมองมองทางขวามือว่ามอเตอร์ไซค์จะมา
หรือเปล่าค่ะเขาคก็จะชินว่าอ้อคนจะรอแล้ว
ก็หยุดแล้วเขาก็จะไปอืหรือว่าเขาอาจจะ
รีบแต่ก็เพราะว่าที่ครูนิคิดว่าว่าเ้าอาจ
จะคิดว่าเค้าเป็นเหมือนจักรยานเนี่ยเพราะ
หลายครั้งที่เห็นเค้าขับบนเลนของ
จักรยานคุณนี่คะอันนั้นคือเค้าเค้าเอา
ความสะดวกสบายของตัวเองหรือ
เปล่าคือแต่คครูนิดก็ครุนิดก็คิดว่าคือ
ที่ไทยอ่ะถ้าเราพูดเกี่ยวกับจราจรเนี่ย
อืมคุณนิว่าน้อยคน
คิดว่าน่าจะประมาณ 30
40% คนจะไม่ค่อยทำตามกฎจราจรเท่าไหร่คน
เค้าบอกว่าทำตามใจตัวเองใช่ออแต่มอยากไป
ก็
ไปก็คนไทยก็จะถ้าอยากทำอะไรที่ไม่ใช่ตาม
กฎจราจรก็จะมองซ้ายมองขวาโอเคไม่มีตำรวจ
ได้ไปได้ออใช่เพราะว่าเหมือนอย่างที่
เนี่ยที่ต่างประเทศเนี่ยที่ครูนิสังเกต
ถ้าเป็นทางข้ามที่คนไทยจะเรียกว่าทางม้า
ลายใช่มั้ยครับค่ะทางม้าลายเนี่ยถ้ามัน
เป็นถ้ามันไม่ได้มีสัญญาณไฟให้กดแต่เขาก็
จะรู้กันว่าถ้ามีคนจะข้ามเขาจะต้องจอดให้
ข้ามอืแต่ที่ไทยเนี่ยไม่ใช่
ค่ะคือถ้าไม่มีไฟให้กดว่าข้ามเนี่ยโอ้โห
ก็ต้องเสี่ยงดวงเอาเลยนะคือลุ้นเอเลยว่า
จะโดนชนมั้ยออหรือว่าเราที่เป็นคนจะข้าม
ทางม้าลายเราต้องรออืให้รถไปก่อนใช่อเออ
ขนาเราเราก็นิครุนิก็เลยคิดว่าแล้วทำไม
ถึงต้องมีทางม้าลายให้ห้ามแบบนั้นในเมื่อ
คนก็คนขับรถหรือรถที่ผ่านไปมาเค้าก็ไม่
ได้สนใจอือย่างไม่ไม่รู้ว่าครูนิเห็นข่าว
หรือเปล่านะคะอันนี้มันเป็นข่าวอืครูหญิง
ไม่แน่ใจว่า 2 เดือนที่แล้วมยมันมีแบบทาง
ม้าลายอยู่ข้างหน้าโรงเรียนน่ะค่ะค่ะแต่
โรงเรียนอ่าไม่ใช่ที่กรุงเทพฯนะอันนี้ไม่
ใช่ที่กรุงเทพฯก็มีโรงเรียนตรงนี้เนาะ
แล้วก็เป็นถนนนะคะแล้วก็เป็นทางม้าลาย
แล้วก็มีเด็กนักเรียนเนี่ยเด็กผู้หญิงน่า
จะประมาณ 5-6 คนกำลังเดินข้ามทางม้าลายนั
แบบตอนเช้ามากๆอ่ะค่ะประมาณแบบ 600 นอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยเด็กไทยก็ไปโรงเรียนแล้วเนาะ
18:00
นแล้วเด็กอ่ะกำลังเดินข้ามทางม้าลายแล้ว
แบบมีมอเตอร์ไซค์อ่ะค่ะขี่มาครับแล้วก็
เห็นนะมอเตอร์ไซค์อ่ะเห็นว่าเด็กผู้หญิง
อ่ะค่ะกำลังข้ามทางม้าลายแต่มอเตอร์ไซค์
ไม่จอดอ้าวเด็กก็คงคิดว่ามอเตอร์ไซค์จะ
จอดก็คือชนเด็กผู้หญิง 1 คน
อ๋อแล้วแต่ว่าก็คือเด็กผู้หญิง 1 คนเนี่ย
ก็คือเหมือนเหมือนโดนชนก็ตัวลอยนิดหน่อย
อ่ะเนาะอ่าก็ไปโรงพยาบาลนะคะแต่โอเคไม่
ได้ไม่ไม่ได้เสียชีวิตเหมือนเคสอื่นนะ
แล้วมอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยคือตรงตรงสี่แยกตรง
นั้นน่ะค่ะมันมีกล้องที่มันจับได้ก็
มอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยพอโดนตำรวจจับครับก็บอก
ว่าอ๋อเขาเห็นเด็กผู้หญิงนะแต่เขารีบอื
เขาต้องไปทำงานตั้งแต่เช้าครับคือเราก็
แบบโอ้โหรอเด็กข้ามประมาณอ่ะ 5 นาทีคงไม่
เป็นไรมั้งคือจริงๆเค้าที่เขาพูดเนี่ยมัน
ก็
เออมันก็ไม่ดีนะเพราะว่าเราจะเอาคือเค้า
จะทำเป็นข้ออ้างแบบนั้นมันไม่ได้อืในที่
คูณนิคิดนะเพราะว่ารีบ
แล้วยังไงล่ะถ้าเกิดว่ารีบเราทำผิดกฎ
จราจรได้ใช่มั้ยเออแล้วแบบมีทางม้าลายเอา
ไว้ทำไมถ้าคุณแบบยากทำอะไรก็ทำใช่แล้วมัน
ก็ไม่ได้นานเพราะว่าถ้าคือครูนิก็คิดว่า
ทางม้าลายที่ให้คนข้ามเนี่ยถ้าไม่ได้อยู่
ในกรุงเทพฯมันก็อาจจะเป็นถนนที่ไม่ได้
ใหญ่เหมือนกับเป็นแค่ถนนเล็กๆเหมือนเป็น
ซอยข้ามประมาณนั้นมัน
ก็ไม่เข้าใจว่าถ้ารอก็รอแป๊บเดียวอืใช่
ค่ะดูจากในภาพน่าจะประมาณแบบถนนประมาณ 4
เลนน่ะไปทางนี้ 2 เลเลนแล้วก็มาทางนี้ 2
เลนไม่ได้ใหญ่ขนาดนั้นไม่ได้ใหญ่ใช่ก็คือ
ขนาดปกติทั่วไปเนาะค่ะอืแล้วเหมือน
มอเตอร์ไซค์ก็ไม่ได้เหมือนรถใช่มั้ยคะรถ
เนี่ยมันต้องใช้แบบประมาณ 1 เลนเลยแต่
มอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยคันเล็กๆใช่เออคือถ้าคน
ข้ามถนนเนี่ยยังไม่พ้นแต่มันมีช่องตรง
เนี้ยเค้าก็ไปได้นะใช่ใช่คือแคือถ้าเกิด
ว่าเปรียบเทียบมอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยคนเดินแค่
3 ก้ามันเคก็ขับผ่านไปได้แล้วอืใช่ค่ะ
แต่ส่วนใหญ่แล้วเนี่ยเวลาข้ามทางม้าลาย
ที่ประเทศไทยอ่ะนะคะแล้วมันจะอันตรายอ่ะ
เนาะแล้วเรารู้สึกไม่ปลอดภัยมากๆก็จาก
มอเตอร์ไซค์อือืใช่ๆพูดถึงทางมลัยจริง
จริงๆอันเนี้ยครับคครูนิก็เห็นว่ามีใน
ประเทศไทยเยอะเหมือนกันอเวลาข้ามถนนก็คือ
สะพานลอย
อ๋อถ้าเกิดอ่ะครูนิกจะให้ครูหญิงเลือก
ระหว่างสะพานรอสะพานลอยกับทางม้าลายเนี่ย
ถ้ามันอยู่ใกล้ๆกันผู้หญิงจะใช้อะไร
คือสภาครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะก็เลือกทางม้าลาย
ค่ะครูนิกทำไมครับคครูนิคะสะพานลอยเนี่ย
เราต้องขึ้นบันไดขึ้นๆๆๆๆๆขึ้ๆๆบันไดแล้ว
ก็เดินแล้วก็ลงๆๆๆๆๆลงบันไดอืลงบันได
เนี่ยไม่เท่าไหร่นะคะแต่ขึ้นบันไดเแบบอื
แค่คิดก็เหนื่อยแล้วอ่ะแต่ทางมลายมันมัน
ง่ายกว่าไงอืแล้วถ้าเป็นครูนิกอ่ะเอ่อถ้า
เป็นครูนิกนะจริงๆคุณนิกจะเลือกสะพานลอย
เอออันนี้ว่าเนี่ยอันเนี้ยคือสะพานลอยม
มันต้องขึ้นบันไดเออบันไดมันเยอะใช่มั้
ครับแล้วมันก็ข้ามใช่ค่ะคือที่ครูนิก
เนี่ยเลือกสะพานลอยเพราะครูนิกรู้สึกว่า
มันปลอดภัยกว่าอ่ะอันนี้ใช่ๆใช่แต่เอา
จริงๆมันปลอดภัยกว่ามยก็ไม่ใช่ 100% นะ
เพราะว่าเนี่ยครูถ้าครูหญิงเห็นอันเนี้ย
ครับมันเป็นสะพานรอยที่เป็นเหล็กค่ะแล้ว
มันมีเสาไฟ
ฟ้าแต่ถ้าฝนตกโอ้โหโคือคุณนิก็คิดเหมือน
กันนะว่าตอนที่เา้าทำสะพานลอยเป็นเหล็ก
แบบเนี้ยเค้าคิดอะไรอยู่เพราะว่าพอคุณนิก
อ่ะตอนแรกๆที่คุณนิกขึ้นสะพานรอยที่เป็น
เหล็กแบบเนี้ยนะพอขึ้นไปข้างบนสุดเ้าก็จะ
มีใ้ายบอกว่าให้ระวังเพราะว่ามันอยู่ใกล้
กับเสาไฟฟ้าอันนี้เออแล้วถ้ามันมีฝนตกมัน
มีอันตรายได้ว่าไฟฟ้ามันจะช็อตเราเออใช่
คุณนิก็บอกคุณนิก็คิดว่าแล้วทำไมต้องมี
ป้ายอันนี้อยู่ข้างบนตอนที่เราขึ้นไป
แล้วทำไมไม่มีตั้งแต่ตอนแรกๆเพราะว่าใช่
ทำไมป้ายไม่อยู่ตั้งแต่บันไดขั้นที่ 1
เพราะคุณนิคิดว่าถ้าเป็นคนที่กลัวเนี่ยเค
เห็นแบบนั้นน่ะเก็
โอ๊ยขึ้นมาจนข้างบนสุดแล้วทำไมถึงมีป้าย
แล้วเขาก็กลัวแต่เขาก็อ้าขึ้นมาแล้วอืใช่
เพราะแบบคือจะลงหรือว่าจะเดินต่อเหมือน
กันไงเพราะว่าขึ้นมาแล้วอ่ะทำอะไรไม่ได้
แล้วใช่ๆก็คือถ้าไม่ใช่สัพานที่เป็นเหล็ก
แบบนั้นเนี่ยครูนิกโอเคค่ะแต่ถ้าเป็น
เหล็กแบบนั้นครูนิกต้องคิดก่อนใช่แต่ว่า
แบบแต่ถ้าเป็นคนไทยอย่างคครูนิกกับครู
หญิงเนี่ยยังเดินขึ้นบันไดได้ไม่เหนื่อย
มากเออแต่แบบคนไทยที่เขาแก่ๆหน่อยอ่ะถ้า
เขาคมีสะพานลอยแล้วก็ทางม้าลายคนแก่ส่วน
ใหญ่เขาก็จะเลือกทางม้าลายอืเพราะว่าบาง
ทีเาขึ้นบันไดไม่ไหวไงคะแบบขใชไม่โอเคแต่
ข้ามทางม้าลายข้ามถนนน่ะนะก็อันตรายใช่
แต่แต่จะว่าไปคนไทยก็ข้ามทุกที่เนาะไม่
ได้ข้ามทางม้าลายอย่างเดียวใช่คือคุณนนี่
คิดว่าคนไทยข้ามทุกที่เพราะว่า
เค้าในความคิดครูนิกนะครูนิกคิดว่าเพราะ
เค้าเพราะรถไม่จอดอยู่ดีถ้าเขาต้องข้าม
ทางม้าลายเาก็เลยคิดว่าแล้วจะข้ามทางม้า
ลายมอืถ้าเป็นทางม้าลายที่เรากดไฟรอนน่ะ
โอเคคนจะข้ามแต่ถ้ามันไม่มีไฟให้กดแล้ว
ข้ามได้เนี่ยคนไทยก็คิดว่าข้ามตรงไหนก็
ได้เพราะรถไม่จอดอยู่ดีใช่หรือว่าแบบทาง
ม้าลายตรงที่เป็นสี่แยกอ่ะที่เป็นมีถนน
เป็นสี่แยกครับตรงทางมะลายก็คือมีรถรถจอด
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปจอดบางทีมันก็ข้ามไม่ได้อื
ใช่อก็แบบข้ามตรงไหนก็
ได้แต่ครูนิกเพิ่งคิดได้ว่าสะพานลอยอ่ะ
ครูหญิงเคยเห็นสะพานลอยที่มันเป็นทางลาดไ
คือมันไม่ได้เป็นขั้นบันไดนะเป็นแบบเป็น
อย่างงี้ใช่มยคะเออหรือเป็นแบบเหมือนเา
เรียกว่าอะไรมันวนๆด้วยอ่ะคือให้สำหรับ
อาจจะคุณนี้คิดว่าอาจจะเป็นเอ่อรถเข็น
หรือคนที่มีจักรยานที่ไม่ต้องยกเยอะก็อาจ
จะขี่จักรยานขึ้นไปได้เลยอืใช่แต่นี้เคย
เห็นแบบกรุงเทพฯไม่เคยเห็นนะคะแต่ว่าแถว
แบบบ้านผู้หญิงอ่ะมีนะอืเป็นอันนี้คือ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ขึ้นได้เลยนะคะคุณนิกเหมือน
ให้เหมือนเขาเป็นสะพานรอยให้มอเตอร์ไซค์
ขี่ได้ด้วยอ่ะอ๋อแต่ที่ไทยจริงๆกรุงเทพฯ
มีที่เหรอที่คุนิเคยเคยเห็นเนี่ยจะอยู่
แถวเส้นวิภาวดีอ่ะพวกจตุจากทางไปดอนเมือง
ตรงนั้นอแต่กนั้นน่ะเจะห้ามเลยห้ามจากไก
เอ่อห้ามมอเตอร์ไซค์ขึ้น
อ๋อแต่ถ้าครับต่างจังหวัดนี่เา้าให้
มอเตอร์ไซค์ได้นะมอเตอร์ไซค์ก็จะขี่
เหมือนขี่ข้ามถนนน่ะค่ะครับเนี่ยมันจะ
เป็นสภาพออันนี้เออเขาคห้ามมอเตอร์ไซค์
ใช่ภาพมันไม่ค่อยชัดนิดหน่อยค่ะอันเนี้ย
ครับมันก็จะเป็นทางราดแบบนี้แต่ผู้หญิง
เห็นมว่าเป็นทางราดนะแต่ตรงเนี้ยมันก็ยัง
ไม่ราดเท่าไหร่นะรถเข็นก็ยากอยู่นะเออมัน
ขึ้นไม่ได้นะต้องยกนะคะครับคือครูนิกก็
คิดว่าเค้าทำทางราดเนี่ยใช่แต่ก็คือทำให้
คนที่เขาขึ้นบันไดไม่ไหวมันก็เป็นทางที่
เขาเดินง่ายกว่าอือๆๆมันก็เหนื่อยน้อย
กว่านะคะแบบหัวเข่าอะไรว่าเห็นมว่าอย่าง
ตรงเนี้ยมันก็มีเหมือนเป็นที่โอ้ทำไมมัน
ยิ่งเล็กเล็กๆอันเนี้ยครับมันก็จะมีที่
กั้นอืเหมือนกับให้คนเท่านั้นค่ะ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ขี่ก็จะไปไม่ได้ใช่จริงๆ
จักรยานก็อาจจะได้แต่แค่ว่าห้ามขี่บน
สะพานรอยอาจจะลากไปด้วยได้อืใช่เนาะใช่
แต่ถ้าสมมุตินักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนะคะแล้ว
มีสะพานลอยกับทางม้าลายก็ให้นักเรียน
เลือกสะพานลอยนะน่าจะปลอดภัยกว่านะคะแต่
ถ้าเกิดว่ามันยากหรือมันเหนื่อยก็ดูถนนดี
ๆเวลาข้ามทางม้าลายครับใช่ค่ะเนาะก็ดูดู
เยอะๆนะคะหรือว่าดูดูมีคนไทยกำลังจะข้าม
ก็เดินข้ามพร้อมคนไทยก็ไปนะจ้าก็ไปใช่ค่ะ
ใช่ๆๆ
โอเคโอเคค่ะครับวันนี้ก็ประมาณนี้เวลาหมด
ใชใช่ค่ะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ใน
วีีดีโอหน้านะคะครับโอเคครับส
สดี